et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
philippe ballard bonjour jai beaucoup
d'être avec nous et porte parole du
rassemblement national candidat aux
législatives dans l'oise et on va
évidemment parler de ces législatives
eric zemmour a donc officialisé hier sa
candidature il sera candidat dans le var
est ce que vous maintenez un candidat
face à lui aiea candidate investie dans
le dans le var absolument de mémoire
eric zemmour a dû faire 15 % dans cette
circonscription marine le pen le double
donc voilà les données du problème pour
pour lui mais il veut au combat voilà
c'est bien jean luc mélenchon lui ce
plan qu'un compris qu'il serait pas
candidat à sa propre succession
on salue oui c'est bien d'aller voilà
c'est la démocratie on se présente à une
élection pour défendre ses idées ses
convictions là on l'a dit des points
d'accord on a aussi quelques points d
accord je pense à la retraite c'est pour
ça aussi qui a pas eu d'accord d'état
major est un majeur parce que
non mais il ya un problème de cohérence
en aurait investi un candidat
imaginons allant dans son sens une sorte
d'union des droites on investit un
candidat aux conquêtes à la place d'à et
rennes est arrivé à l'assemblée
nationale on n'aura pas eu forcément les
voeux des votes similaire par exemple
sur la retraite
on peut imaginer que le député
reconquête auraient voté la réforme
proposée par emmanuel macron la réforme
à 65 ans nous on est foncièrement contre
les mots qu'il a eus quand même le soir
du deuxième tour quand il dit le nom le
pen est une nouvelle fois associés pour
la xm fois une défaite je pense que
c'est pas forcément quand on veut faire
une une alliance est peut-être pas
forcément ce qu'il ya de plus habile
après oui il ya une campagne électorale
où effectivement il peut y avoir des des
mots doux d'échangés mais bon il ya un
moment faut peut-être savoir savoir
arrêter et puis c'est bien beau de
parler d'union mais enfin rappelons nous
la présidentielle quand même s'il règle
zemmour avait fait un point de plus le
deuxième tour c'était mélenchon macron
voilà fossiles avoir en mémoire y
apprennent de cohérence dans sa démarche
récemment puisque vous parlez de
cohérence nicolas dupont aignan lui
aussi nicolas dupont aignan
avait fait un point de plus elle
n'aurait pas été au second tour en temps
vous mettez pas de candidat face à lui
allé où la grand-mère en lice il s'est
bien comporté durant cette campagne
électorale nicolas dupont aignan il
était dans son couloir il a fait sa
campagne mais enfin voila il a défendu
ses idées il n'a pas été
comportement si raymond n'avait pas dix
duels de marine le pen pendant la
campagne vous n'auriez pas mine candidat
face à lui et peut-être que rien n'a
encore pensé il ya des propos qui
peuvent être foncièrement blessant il ya
des attitudes aussi de certains qui ont
rejoint eric zemmour qui n'ont pas
forcément été clean comme on dit en très
mauvais français donc ça laisse
laissé des traces à l'ess même des
traces
non c'est je pense que c'est un cas un
peu un peu à part c'était pas nommé ya
une différence entre ceux qui ont été
élus au ca des deux eurodéputés une
étiquette et rennes qui faisait moore
quoique il y en a d'autres et qui d'un
seul coup tout en gardant leur mandat
d'accord
rejoindre marion maréchal n'avait plus
de demandes a depuis
les dernières depuis 2010 est est ce que
c'est quand même pas une erreur
stratégique est ce que vous n'aurez pas
besoin d'eric zemmour et de ses
électeurs dans ces législatives où a
priori compte tenu de l'abstention il y
aura énormément de duels ailleurs a
priori il n'y aura que des duels
d'ailleurs on se souvient qu'en 2017 il
ya eu une seule triangulaire puisque
rappelons le est fait il faut faire 12
5% des inscrits pour être au 2e tour
donc effectivement il y aura des des
duels quasiment partout vous savez lors
de la présidentielle toutes les études
d'opinion montrent que quasiment 80 %
des électeurs d'eric zemmour ont voté
marine le pen au deuxième tour donc
voilà il ya un mouvement naturel qui
s'opèrent après celle en ligne on
sait pas récupérer c'est je veux dire il
ya quand même beaucoup d'éléments
communs dans notre programme avec ce que
pense ce que ressent ce que souhaitent
ses électeurs donc tout simplement au
deuxième tour mais on les appelle dès le
premier tour on rappeler cette règle des
12 5% des inscrits à faire le choix
utiles s'ils sont patriotes s'ils sont
nationaux s'ils sont souverainistes à
voter pour les candidats qui incarne le
mieux l'opposition à emmanuel macron à
savoir les candidats du rassemblement
national est-ce que vous misez sur la
défaite
j'ordonne bardella l'a dit on
travaillera avec les députés reconquête
s'il y en ad lui on pourra voir les
points de divergence je parlais de la
retraite il y à quelques instants mais
on travaillera avec eux et jordan
bardella l'a dit s'il ya un candidat
reconquête devant le candidat
rassemblement national on appellera
désistement en sa faveur et justement
jardin de nadal a abordé la lancée cette
semaine la campagne
votre repartir la marine le pen elle
était allée au 20 heures a dit qu'elle
ambitionne passe de devenir premier
ministre emmanuel macron aura une
majorité est-ce que c'est pas un peu
démotivant pour vos électeurs de se
lancer dans une campagne en disant qu'on
va la perdre non mais on y est on est
lucide on regarde les cartes électorales
voilà on n'est pas comme monsieur
mélenchon qui joue est le premier
ministre c'est à ces annonces c'est d'un
grotesque total et absolu fin voilà ces
supports est de l'intox ou fâchés parce
qu'ils ce qu'il souhaite faire voilà non
mais bien sûr qu'ils se rassurent
auteurs oui
c'est sûr mais non il suffit de regarder
une carte électorale je veux dire
évidemment que jean luc mélenchon n'a
aucune chance d'être majoritaires à
l'assemblée nationale et donc par
ricochet de devenir premier ministre
donc voilà on regarde des cartes
électorales d'où les propos de marine le
pen on peut former un très gros groupe à
l'assemblée nationale combien c'est
plusieurs dizaines plusieurs dizaines de
députés mais voilà on va laisser le
scrutin se déroulait il ya quand même
deux sondages qui ont été enfin
plusieurs sondages mais qui allaient
dans la même voie après le deuxième tour
dans la majorité de ces sondages ont
tous les sondages même les français
disaient c'est une mauvaise chose qui
est belle macro et été réélu président
de la république et d'autres sondages
disaient il faut que ce soit
l'opposition qu'ils soient majoritaires
à l'assemblée nationale donc pas de
majorité pour renaissance pour emmanuel
macron donc on aura peut-être une bonne
surprise le 12 et le 19 juin mais
justement pourquoi ne pas ambitionner
d'avoir autre chose qu'une dizaine de
députés et de gagner regarde la carte
électorale on sait très bien où sont nos
places fortes on peut avoir des députés
et il y en a d'autres parce que il ya ce
mode de scrutin uninominal à deux tours
qui nous favorise pas mais bon voilà
encore une fois je suis ce qui était des
sondages qui peuvent laisser enfin
entrevoir une bonne
voilà quelque chose de tout à fait
agréable le 19 juin au soir à partir de
combien de députés vous direz vous avez
une juste représentation contenu ah bah
moi je verserai la question ici la
proportionnelle été mise en place on
pourrait peut-être devenir majoritaire
là pour le coup bien vous situer le
encore une fois plusieurs dizaines
d'hectares qui a été réalisé qui nous
donnaient entre
85 et 125 députés ça sera peut-être un
peu plus ce sera peut-être un peu moins
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est la participation il ya eu 71 % de
participation à la présidentielle aux
législatives de 2010 est c'était 50 % au
premier tour et 43 % de participation on
l'a un peu oublié c'est la première fois
qu'il y avait moins d'électeurs au
deuxième tour qu'au premier tour donc
voilà les coraux battu
et c'est là où j'allais revenir quand le
peuple vote le peuple gagne pour
reprendre ce que disait marine le pen
lors de la présidentielle il faut
absolument que ceux qui subissent cette
politique injuste parce que le nouveau
quinquennat des manades macro on a
compris c'est la casse sociale et
c'était la saignée fiscale sans parler
de la sécurité de vagues migratoires
déferlante etc etc donc il faut
absolument qu'il n'est pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale donc votez votez
vous qui avait du mal à finir les fins
de mois le 10 du mois vous vous demandez
comment vous allez finir ce ce même mois
vous qui vivez la sécurité au quotidien
déplacez-vous le 12 et le 19 allez voter
pour les candidats du rassemblement
national attaque beaucoup jean luc
mélenchon depuis son entrée en campagne
votre adversaire
c'est les deux c'est emmanuel macron
parce que c'est lui qui est installé à
l'elysée est mécaniquement c'est vrai
que généralement il a une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale donc
et c'est aussi jean luc mélenchon qui
présente un programme extrêmement
néfaste pour pour la france il ya
vraiment danger bailly les indigènes
east c'est le oak hills pas l'état pur
il est pour désarmer les policiers nous
on est pour la présente sur légitime
défense pour les policiers il veut vider
les prisons nous on est on veut mettre
fin au laxisme en matière judiciaire etc
etc marine le pen elle reproche aussi à
jean luc mélenchon d'avoir fait lire
bah oui en quoi il a plus fait rire
emmanuel macron on se souvient de ses
phrases du premier tour pas une voix
pour marine le pen pas une voix pour
marine le pen
c'est par ricochet du voix pour emmanuel
macron alors maintenant il peut cheminer
pleurer sur la retraite à 65 ans mais
mieux s'est pas renversé la casserole un
robert ménard qui est soutien quelque
peu critique certes mais soutien de
marine le pen estime qu'une majorité
pour macron serait un moindre mal face
au danger que représente jean luc
mélenchon êtes d'accord avec ça non mais
je pense que jean luc mélenchon encore
une fois le son projet est dangereux
pour pour la france je pense qu'il
voudrait en fait lui et tous ses
soutiens vol des structures et la france
veulent détruire la france il son
confident cités françaises ils sont pour
l'indigénisme ils sont pour le bikini
dans les piscines ou on est pour
l'interdiction du voile dans l'espace
public c'est un projet extrêmement
néfaste weepu
non je ne formulerai pas comme ça mais
neil macron je viens de vous dire c'est
la casse sociale c'est la saignée
fiscale à l'arrivée
c'est pas bon
mais non bah on vote pour les candidats
du rassemblement national
nous on est respectueux des institutions
parce qu'entre les deux tours ans est
pris à longueur d'interviews vous êtes
d'extrême droite n'auront n'est pas
d'extrême droite on respecte les
institutions ça on arrêtait d'extrême
droite en 2017 marine le pen fait plus
de 11 millions de voix on se retrouve
avec sept députés il ya paul 6 février
34 nos militants n'ont pas marché sur
l'assemblée nationale en dix ans le
système est antidémocratique on respecte
les institutions donc bah voilà les
français vont voter ils vont s'exprimer
et évidemment on les encourage à voter
pour les candidats du rassemblement
national pour ne pas voir une majorité
pour macron ne pas avoir une majorité
pour mélenchon et son husky par un
corbillard entre parenthèses pourquoi
bon ben je sais pas j'ai écouté
mais pas que les dissidents socialistes
tout ce qui se passe ça me rappelle un
peu ce qui s'est passé aux régionales en
île de france parce que j'étais candidat
tête de liste à paris en fait les trois
listes y avait une liste les filles unie
socialisme une liste écolo qui ont
fusionné au deuxième tour et ça a été on
aurait pu prendre une calculette c'était
leur score du premier tour additionnés
il ya eu aucune dynamique et la gauche
en france est allée 28% à peu près 28 29
27% donc content jean luc mélenchon dit
je serai le premier ministre en faisant
26 27 voitures sont une fois
ça s'adressait devrait faire pschitt
comme un ancien président de la
république
a confirmé qu'il ne serait pas candidat
il passe la main son directoire de
campagne manuel bompard qu'il sera
candidat dans sa circonscription
non mais c'est ce c'est ce défi et non
il ne s'est jamais fait oui je pense
qu'ils défilent parce que après il
n'aura pas la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale il sera pas député hilare pas
de tribune bon je sais pas qu'est ce
qu'il va faire
qui n'aura plus
deux voies
oui fin je vois là mais c'est pas notre
problème mais je vois là quand on
annoncera sa vie se débrouille eux mêmes
gens suffisamment je pense de problèmes
à gérer en interne avec des candidats
qu'on souhaite positionner puis que l'on
obligé de retirer parce qu'on découvre
qu'il y a potentiellement des problèmes
de harcèlement de etc etc je pense
qu'avant celle de voir si je
sois ils sont incompétents soit ils
mentent il ya un problème quand même
lâché chez les filles 1 monsieur boeuf
haché par an visiblement il savait mais
ils ont soutenu jusqu'au moment où on ne
peut plus soutenir un candidat potentiel
donc voilà
ils sont incompétents qu'ils n'avaient
pas les seuls à dire pour vous c'est un
mensonge quand jean luc mélenchon je
pense que oui c'est un gros mensonge ou
et enfin tout le monde savait sauf lui
ils ont un drôle de fonctionnement quand
même à la france a soumises genre on l'a
bien compris à marine le pen elle
envisage la tête de l'imposition du coup
mélenchon est ce qu'il n'a pas pris une
longueur d'avancé ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait une erreur marine le pen en
s'absentant en s'absentant plusieurs
jours après la présidentielle la scala
pas laisser le terrain le champ libre à
jean luc mélenchon non mais déjà à ce
jour enfin on dit jean luc mélenchon la
dynamique le nul chez eux est en train
de retomber ça fait pschitt mais je
pense que marine le pen 1 avait droit à
quelques jours de repos après le
deuxième tour et cette longue bataille
il faut se souvenir quand même qu'elle a
commencé en septembre dernier aller sur
le terrain de trois déplacements par
jour en suisse il y a eu comme on dit la
période médiatique il n'y en avait que
pour la gauche cette pseudo union jean
luc mélenchon avec les occuper le
terrain médiatique
c'est fini maintenant leno séquence qui
s'ouvre marine le pen revient sur le
terrain elle visite évidemment ça sert
déception mais pas que le faire d'autres
déplacements en france comme elle sait
si bien
les cibler des circonscriptions à se
déplacer en france ce we have a déplacé
enfants sur le sait très bien non plus
jacques lasserre exelmans wifo support
fleuron de la marine façon à son équipe
assez fière de sa garde rapprochée
jordan bardella aussi se déplace sur le
terrain voilà on fait campagne elle fait
l'été les elfes et les radios voilà on
est reparti en campagne il ya un mois de
campagne avant le avant le 12 juin et
marine et là évidemment quand même jean
luc mélenchon on va juste regarder la
une du point de cette semaine le point
qui est sorti hier avec ce titre jean
luc mélenchon l'autre le pen qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ce qui est trés de
santé
c'est pas la meilleure une alors la
vérité sur monsieur mélenchon j'ai pas
lu le point alors je sais pas ce qu'il
ya après
non c'est pas du tout le tour le pen on
a commencé à pointer quelques points de
divergence par exemple je vous parlais
du burkina dans les piscines jean luc
mélenchon est pour nous on est pour
l'interdiction du port du voile dans
l'espace public il est pour désarmer la
police nous on est pour la présomption
de légitime défense pour nos forces de
l'ordre il veut vider les prisons nous
on veut mettre fin au laxisme judiciaire
il est indigéniste nous pour la défense
de l'identité française et puis c'est
quelqu'un d' antisociale quand même
monsieur mélenchon et antisociales abat
sur la retraite par exemple parce que
lui veut la retraite à 60 ans pour tout
le monde alors il a été interrogé à
plusieurs reprises a su quelqu'un qui
commence à travailler à 20 ans pourra
partir à 60 ans donc avec 40 annuités il
a travaillé quarante annuités quelqu'un
qui rentre dans la vie active à à 25 26
27 ans qui a donc fait a priori des
études qui aura un métier un peu moins
pénible que celui qui aura commencé à 20
ans parce qu'il aura donc fait les
études il aura un bureau avec des
moulures au plafond la climatisation
l'été l'hiver ça sera chauffée
contrairement à quelqu'un qui travaille
sur des chantiers il pourra partir à 60
ans autrement dit c'est quelqu'un qui
aura travaillé 34 35 ans et qui partira
aussi à 60 ans donc c'est l'injustice
sociale annuités non non non non pas
dans le projet alors joueront ali
interview sur une chaîne de télé à 20
heures la semaine dernière de jean luc
mélenchon où il ya dix-sept personnes
qui a commencé à travailler à 23 ans est
l âge qui étaient cités partir à 60 ans
donc c'est socialement injuste voilà
jean luc mélenchon n'est pas social
on est pour la retraite à 60 ans pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
17 et 20 ans l'âge légal à 62 ans et
ensuite effectivement on craint comme
l'on dit tous les six mois un trimestre
supplémentaire à partir de 20 ans c'est
à dire que on pourra partir à 62 ans si
on a commencé ce genre prends mon
exemple à 26 ans mais on n'aura pas une
retraite à taux plein effectivement sur
quoi vont aux candidats vont faire
campagne sur quoi vous allez faire
campagne à leur
assemblée législative c'est la suite de
la présidentielle donc semblé maintien
même si sur le pouvoir d'achat moi je
suis candidat aux législatives et on me
parle de deux choses essentiellement
alors c'est une circonscription qui est
rural et puis perry péri urbaines comme
l'on dit pouvoir d'achat on est obligé
d'avoir une ou deux voitures donc le 10
du mois on se demande comment on va
faire
j'écoutais le sénateur tu es mal et on a
peut-être on peut avoir d un point
d'accord il prenait une bonne image
quand on ouvre le frigo on voit la
lumière parce qu'il ya plus d'un an doit
arbitrer entre faire le plein pour aller
travailler pour aller chercher les
enfants à l'école ou bien remplir le
frigo et puis la sécurité parce qu'il
n'ya aucune zone en france où on est à
l'abri de cette insécurité qui n'est pas
qu'un sentiment mais qu'il a réédité
millions de français est-ce que sur
cette question du pouvoir d'achat
emmanuel mac on n'est pas en train de
vous couper l'herbe sous le pied il a
annoncé s'il obtient une majorité aux
législatives évidemment il y aura une
loi pouvoir d'achat une fois les
législatives terminé avec plusieurs
mesures le chèque alimentaire
l'indexation des retraites et des
prestations sociales sur l'inflation
les aides pour l'énergie et qui
continueront est-ce qu'il n'est pas en
train de vous couper leur couple et est
ce que vous allez soutenir ces mesures
est ce que vos députés élus soutiendront
c'est majeur il ya deux choses déjà
échec c'est une fois à une fois qu'on
les puissances souvient du début de
l'année les gens sur un chèque de
quelques dizaines d'euros dont des
détenus d'ailleurs jamais compris
pourquoi ça a payé même pas un plein
voilà une fois qu'on a utilisées chèque
on se débrouille après sur les mesures
l'indexation par exemple des retraites
c'était dans notre programme et ses
manuels mâcon qu'il arrêtait donc mon un
peu de cohérence
marine le pen l'a dit on regardera
mesure par mesure celles qui peuvent
aller dans le bon sens effectuant une
mesure comme celle là puisqu'on l'avait
dans notre programme
on l'a on la soutient drame et enfin un
peu de cohérence monsieur mac ont quand
même
la suite lapret législatives ce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura une recomposition
politique après les législatives et est
ce que l'union qui ne s'est pas faite
notamment avec reconquête avant les
législatives pourra se faire après
n'oubliez pas enfin encore une fois
cette union des droits de certains c'est
un ancien monde puis pardon mais c'est
un peu petit bras voilà marine le pen ce
qu'elle a voulu furent mandat
présidentiel est ce que jordan veut
faire à présent pour ces législatives
c'est rassembler les patriotes les
nationaux et souverainisme et qu'ils
soient de droite de gauche ou du centre
moi je rencontre en distribuant des
tracts des gens qui me disent vous savez
encore dix ans moi je veux tu es à
gauche mais en fait maintenant j'ai voté
marine le pen je veux très sans doute
pour vous parce que vous êtes des
nationaux on a compris que la
mondialisation heureuse que nous avons
dû la droite que nous avons dû la gauche
que nous avons dû le centre ça nous a
mis là on est maintenant serre dans le
fossé chef d'entreprise d'ailleurs comme
cela et parce qu'on nous a mis en
concurrence avec des pays qui n'ont pas
les mêmes règles fiscales sociales
environnementales donc ça ne pouvait que
mal se terminer et ça ça a été portée
par la droite la gauche se sentent dont
on a une autre vision nous sommes des
nationaux des souverainistes des
patriotes de droite de gauche ou
d'ailleurs mais cela aurait une
recomposition du cou ou est-ce que vous
défendez un autre
mondialiste comptes nationaux
sauf que on le voit dans les territoires
et dans les collectivités ya toujours un
clivage droite gauche comment du coup
vous allez faire pour avec ses
différents clivages que l'on soit sur le
plan national non messieurs on pense pas
qu'ils aient ce clivage droite gauche au
niveau des alors des collectivités des
élus oui mais bon les élus dans le oui
mais je pense que le fond voilà ce
clivage il existe la recomposition va
continuer à se faire avec ce clivage
nationaux entre mondialistes et donc
quand démondialisation on peut
incorporer la france a soumises ils sont
internationaliste dans leur adn c'est à
dire c'est no border pas de frontières
donc ce sont des mondialistes jordan la
belgique marine le pen dirait le 10
septembre la forme que prendra son
engagement politique à venir le jardin
de marie line est bien parti pour rester
à la tête du fn pendant longtemps
écoutez ça faut demander à la fois
marine et à jordan je pense que jordan
bardet il a fait un travail absolument
formidable moelleux face à me ramène à
quelques années en arrière voilà je
faisais un métier riche chose est votre
métier j'avais interviewé il table ronde
mois il m'avait bluffé c'est en 2017 je
pense qu'il a il un boulevard devant lui
jordan quelqu'un de d'exceptionnel donc
voila mon grippale et les étapes marine
a fait une superbe campagne car envie de
revenir à la table de jeu
non mais je pense que quand on fait de
la politique depuis depuis quasiment
qu'on est enfant on peut pas s'en passer
comme ça on peut servir son pays de
différentes façons l'avenir nous livrer
son mari mais marine le pen dira ce
cas-là ce qu'elle souhaite faire ce
qu'elle souhaite faire pour elle pour
pour le pays je veux dire c'est bien
c'est un problème de riche qu'on a nous
voilà on a beaucoup de deux personnes
qui peuvent aller très très loin dans la
vie publique dans la vie politique et
dans les prochaines échéances
électorales derniers mois la vocation à
prendre la présidence du groupe si
évidemment vous arrivez à former un
groupe je pense que évidemment ce enfin
si elle est élue si je suis le chemin au
désistement je pense que j'espère que
marine sera la présidente du hope à
l'assemblée nationale merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]